there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
june to test for ourselves
i did it i bought the jones road beauty
what the foundation this has caused all
kinds of controversy and discourse so i
apologize for also putting in my two
cents this is what it looks like it's
very oily and thick
it has a scent i actually don't mind
it's like a soft spa-like smell i
applied a pretty small amount for me
with my fingers and then went over that
with my sponge and i
did not hate how this looked it's very
skin like it felt like i wasn't even
wearing foundation i will say it tends
to gather in certain areas so i might
have to go in with even less product
my other products layered on top of this
fine but i feel like i like this more as
an everyday skin tint rather than a
foundation base for my makeup like i
would reach for this when i'm running
errands on a sunday morning but not when
i'm going to the club i've been obsessed
with lip oils so i immediately snatched
up this fenty beauty cherry tree
conditioning and strengthening lip oil i
have to start off by saying this is the
most amazing smelling lip product it
smells like cherry candies we got this
giant doe foot applicator i love i did
not want to stop applying this it felt
so nice this formula makes your lips
feel so hydrated and soft and cushiony
if that makes any sense it's also so
glossy the color is so sheer it doesn't
really look like much on my lips but i
love this and it's definitely going in
my bag i also got the fenty beauty
popsicle hydrating lip stain this also
feels so good on the lips every lip
stain i've tried has been more drying
not hydrating so i am really into this
formula it's very pigmented so i was
careful when i was applying to make sure
i didn't get the stain anywhere outside
of my lips after leaving it on for a few
minutes i wiped it off with a paper
towel and there was definitely a pretty
stain left behind that was a hundred
percent transfer proof i can see myself
wearing this a lot this summer if you
can believe it i have never tried a
house lapse product before they recently
rebranded and i picked up a couple of
products first up this house labs high
power pigment paint you can use this
anywhere on the face the pigment in
these actually took me by surprise like
i was not expecting them to be so full
coverage you need like the tiniest
amount of these it blended out pretty
easily on my eyes and it doesn't dry too
quickly so you have some time to work i
am so into these i also picked up the
phd hybrid lip oil this applicator is
much smaller than the fenty one which
made me sad but the actual formula is
really smooth and comfortable on the
lips it's more of a thinner formula than
other lip oils i've tried but i really
loved how this looked and felt this also
has no scent which i prefer over a bad
scent these were great products and i
need to try more uma beauty just
released this trip and smooth powder and
what's so cool about it is how the
powder dispenses you twist it and it
releases the perfect amount of powder
which i love because my powders get so
messy the powder itself is so finely
milled and silky smooth it applied
really nicely and smoothed out my under
eyes a bit so i really liked it i've
been on the hunt for a good talc free
powder and i think this is it the only
thing i wish they had was a translucent
option but this is so good i tried two
products from makeup revolution let's
start with this blush balm cream blusher
this straight up looks and feels like a
lip gloss it was very confusing it's
definitely more of an oily blush formula
than i'm used to first application
wasn't great it's pretty sheer but it
does build up i don't think i like this
though i think it just feels like lip
gloss on my cheeks i also tried the
super fix misting spray i know i just
complained about the blush looking like
a lip gloss but i love that this looks
like a hairspray the mist is nice but i
wish it was a continuous mist i applied
this underneath my makeup and then on
top when i was finished that's how i
like to use a setting spray it melted
the makeup in nicely but i typically
like a more dewy finish and this is
pretty matte i wore this makeup for
eight hours and i think i looked okay at
the end of the day i feel like i could
still see my blush which is usually the
first thing to disappear this isn't my
favorite setting spray but i do think
it's a good cheaper option
pat mcgrath released a new shade of her
skin fetish highlighter and balm duo
this has a bomb on one side and this
really beautiful highlighter on the
other this shade extreme cyber orchid is
so interesting it shifts from a blue to
a lilac and totally disappears at
certain angles this formula is
definitely balmy but not in an oily way
i got so nervous when i first applied it
because this was not blending in at all
but it blended in really nicely when i
used my fingers i think for 58 bucks i
would rather get a more wearable
everyday shade but this formula is
really nice this is the maybelline
tattoo studio brow lipped stick which is
supposed to give you a brow lift or brow
lamination effect at home it has a cool
little brush on one side and then this
colored wax on the other so you brush
your brows up first apply the wax to
fill in and then use the brush to lift
the brow hairs this is a cool idea and i
did like how it made my brows look but
it did take a bit of work i think if
this brush had firmer bristles it would
be easier to get that brow lift effect i
also just don't think this wax is waxy
enough to hold my brows up all day so
this was just okay
[Music]
you